and is starting our event is starting
and we're live okay we are live welcome
back to the weekly poll everybody where
this week we have a special guest AIS
I'm not even going to try his last name
because I'm G to butcher horribly
because I can't even say this stuff on
my own SK scripts properly from variant
comics and normally I'll go over the top
and give you a crazy intro but I've been
told not to do it today so AIS why don't
you explain to us what your channel
is uh my name's Aris last name
konz um my channel is basically I talk
about all I say it this my catchphrase
in in the show I talk about all things
comic so I'll do I do history of
episodes where it's basically it's kind
of like school for you know comic books
where I'll do like a 10-minute breakdown
of like a character that week like
Wonder Woman whatever Batman and then I
review comic books time to time TV shows
movies video games top 10 top five
whatever in the world of comics is out
there I'll talk about it so all things
comics
awesome enough man so um all right so
one of the things that we were going to
talk about today one of the things that
Eric said he wanted to talk about was
Batman Eternal which admittedly like I
don't know anything about Marvel
explained you don't know anything about
Batman Eternal don't know anything about
DC Comics okay I I I actually have a
funny story about about Batman Eternal
real quick for you Eris all right and
this is for you so okay Rob hits me up
yesterday morning and I'm editing my
Deadpool episode and I'm already working
and everything and he hits me up and he
says Aris has one topic that brought up
that he wants to discuss Batman Eternal
and I'm the DC guy and I'm like great I
haven't read Batman Eternal since issue
10 this will be
epic so I run out to the comic book
store I buy issues 11 through
26 I come home and I Blitz read it and
I'm chatting with these guys the whole
time I'm like okay so in issue 15 this
is what happened maybe this is what he
wants to talk about issue 18 here's what
happened maybe this is the
topic what's hilarious about that story
now is you're probably ahead of me cuz
I'm two issues
behind oh crap well then we won't
discuss 25 or 26
so but I Bliss the whole thing down and
I will say before we go into it I
abandoned ship at issue 10 because it
was going nowhere and our main villain
was Dr pig or whatever his name was but
by like yeah but by like issue 189 it
really started to pick up and actually
started like oh what am I reading this
is getting good oh man no I I really
like how like all the well I just like
Scott Snider I guess his team he's
leading team Batman but I really like
what he's doing with how we've got we
got like five different stories going on
so it jumps around a lot so if you're
not reading all of them you're not going
to get it because I might pick off you
know the leave off with Red Robin and a
bgirl and then they'll Skip and do a
story with you know Penny I mean Penny
one I guess Penny one and his
daughter yeah and so it jumps back and
forth but I like how it's covering
everything Batman and now recently I
don't know if this is a spoiler for
anyone but I don't think it is he's on
the cover uh hush has now been
introduced it's first appearance in 52
so that is really cool that he's been in
the last two issues that I've read like
I said I'm like two issues or so behind
but I think it's really cool how they're
bringing him in with hush and then from
there I mean with Batman Eternal and
then from there going into Batman maybe
we'll see him in endgame which could be
really cool maybe that was the the
purpose I know how this end game is
going to the end of Eternal right where
Batman Eternal is setting everything up
so they're doing like a Quinton
Tarantino
like
let's yeah yeah they're doing that whole
thing with the future's end deal you
know where they're setting up the future
and then they're jumping around a time
and you get confused where you're at and
I I agree with you with the hush thing
bringing hush in was great because I
didn't like all the original villains
well yeah like yeah and and the jumping
around in the story is what kind of lost
me I know it's a weekly title so it's
easy to get caught up but even though
it's a weekly title it might be four
issues before we get back to Alfred
pennyworth or might be four issues
before we get back to Batgirl and Red
Robin in South America yeah and you know
because I my stacks are like 30 Comics a
week so that's kind of hard to keep
track of what happened at Batman Eternal
three weeks ago and that that's kind of
what lost me so sitting down and
actually reading it back to back was
really good um yeah it's definitely I
think something that will be better in
trade Andor for like the Diehard Batman
fan who's gonna be reading it every
single week like if you're reading it
casually I guess you could get a little
confusing or maybe if you just like wait
a month do four issues and kind of you
know just like gang read them all I
guess that could be easier that way too
right I'm a huge Batman fan I get a lot
of the Batman books it's just I think
maybe because I read so many Batman
books on top of every other book I read
it's just it was kind of hard to follow
until I sat down and read the whole
thing back to back yeah now reading
through it I and I'm pretty sure this
happened I'm not sure how recent it was
because I don't think it was the last
two issues how do you feel about them
retconning more origin for
Catwoman uh I I kind of like how they're
doing with I like the whole Lion thing I
guess you know that's that's that's
probably a big reveal I don't so spoiler
spoiler
alert uh they're used to us just
spoiling everything
so he's been revealed as her as her
Father which is it's it's kind of the
new 52 in general I kind of like in this
I know a lot of people it's kind of
seems 50-50 at least from my perspective
with people either you love it or you're
kind of like eh I want the original or
the other continuity back but I really
like how I kind of like the changes
because a lot of them are some of them
are dumb but
it's they're more updated it's you know
it's a new audience it's meant for
people who don't really know the old
continuity like you know all of us we we
know it but I'm more accepting I guess
of like change where some people are not
accepting of change yeah so I it doesn't
really bother as long as the writing as
long as it's good which I thought it was
It was kind of cool uh it doesn't bother
me so you could change pretty much
almost anything I mean there's certain
things you need to keep but as long as
you do it well I'm fine with it like
especially I know the big thing in New
52 is their underwear you know
like yeah exactly yeah um yeah and I
agree with you about the new 52 changes
and everything like that the only ones
that really bother me are when they try
to they just like halfhazard Le throw
like oh uh Batman's been done in five
years and we're just not really going to
explain how the whole Robin thing worked
out yeah or blackest Knight is still
happening but we're not going to explain
how that happened so and if black is KN
still work then who died and when and
resurrect half of them like it I I I
like the idea of the new 52 and I like
some of the execution as far as like
sniders Batman has been a breakaway
success for me um Grant Morrison's
Action Comics like one through 10 I
really enjoyed um especially with Rags
Morales on Art it was gorgeous looking
so I was like oh this is like a tent
pole book um but there didn't seem to be
like a really clear road map and that
you need to have that kind of like
editorial Direction in order to make it
I don't know in order to have faith in
it because otherwise they're just going
to undo it or change it or whatever like
there's no permanence then especially
because you've just changed everything
anyway and you've basically said like oh
no nothing is permanent but this is
pered for the you know foreseeable
future so it's it's it's a mixed bag
right yeah I I will say two things
though I know the robin thing I agree
with you that was kind of weird that's
really funky with like so wait a minute
wait a minute this is all five years so
in five years you had five different
exactly and he and he trained Batgirl at
some point in there because apparently
she's been kind of reconed as part of
the family fully now not just on the
side Batwoman the whole thing happened
oh by the way his back was broken still
he also died in final crisis still went
time traveling we're we're still GNA
reference that
but yeah killing jokes still happen but
Barbara Gordon recovered from spinal
injury that's
fine yeah I don't okay so so as a non-dc
person you not like DC like you just
don't like it or you just don't read it
I just haven't really read it like I I
love Marvel Comics I've been reading
Marvel Comics since I was a kid and so
for me like it's always been Marvel I
know about DC like I know of DC and I
mean I know as much as like I've heard
of Superman I've heard of Superman I've
heard of this guy that wears a ring and
does stuff you know like you know I've
heard of
things but um but I checked out hush and
and that guy Thomas Elliott I think was
his name um when that guy First shows up
I guess is this introduction story in
2003 that was
awesome that story actually sounded
really cool because like for me like
coming from like a Marvel perspective it
reminded me a lot of sinister 6 but it
had a really cool twist at the end
because in Sinister 6 like Dr Octopus
was leading everything but in this it
looked like hush was the one that was
like manipulating everything when it
turned out I guess that the Riddler was
actually the one at the end who was more
or less like manipulating hush and then
manipulating all the circumstances that
resulted from it but he seemed like a
really cool character because I guess
what I would expect and again this is
you know from not necessarily reading DC
all the time is that if you're going to
have like a major villain who's going to
come in and who's going to like
challenge Batman and say like I'm going
to more or less try to kill you that you
expect him to be some kind of like super
Goliath character like Bane who's you
know incredibly strong with that stuff
that he uses or you know I I didn't
expect a guy showing up wielding like 45
caliber pistols to like almost lay waste
to Batman it was it was really kind of
interesting to me but but I thought that
story was it was actually a pretty
awesome read a lot better than I thought
it was going to be anyway I totally
agree with you I think that's why part
of the success with uh Batman Court of
Al
because they he did it in a way where
he's made them seem like they were
always a part of Batman's mythology like
they were always there so back in the ne
Adams days you know George Perez
whatever like they were there lurking
behind the like they were they ran
Gotham which was I think why everyone
liked it because he introduced a new
villain that was actually always there
just no one ever talked about it until
he did it which I he pulled it off
flawlessly I thought yeah no I agree
with you and I really enjoyed how Batman
for almost half until he met the quar of
BS was like no they can't exist there's
nothing about Gotham I don't don't know
I know everything yeah that was a great
way that was a great way for them to
actually kick off the Batman stories for
the new 52 like establishing like Batman
is like establishing Batman as like
cemented in the Mythos but also then up
up uplifting it a little bit or
uprooting it a little bit by saying like
yeah but Batman doesn't know everything
right right unleashing this new Foe and
and also kind of changing around like
the and I thought yeah never mind I was
going to say like I thought they were
going to like drop the Earth to thing
like I thought they were going to drop
like yes I I thought yeah with with the
reveal of cour of B which I'm not going
to ruin unless we ruin everything on
this show which we we're pretty good
about that the only thing we never the
only thing we managed to not spoil Aris
was when Guardians of the Galaxy came
out the entire comments yelled at us to
wait a week so
we you better not spoil it yeah all we
did was just talk about how great it was
we're just like yeah it's great we were
just
great what's funny is I I have a joke
with uh my friends and people I work
with like people want me have been
wanting me to review Guardians of the
Galaxy I didn't review it because that
was the same week it was like back
toback with uh Ninja Turtles and then
Guardians of the Galaxy that came back
toback so usually when big movies come
out like that that are comic book
related I'll do a history of episode
because it just makes sense right on
those characters so so I was like so I
had I had it a little like conflict
myself I'm like what would they rather
the following week review of Guardians
of the Galaxy or history of Teenage
Ninja Turtles I went with Ninja Turtles
they they liked it but I still keep
getting to I just got one yesterday when
are you going to review Guardians of the
Galaxy I'm like it's like months old I'm
probably not it was
great it was good good things that's
that's that's my exactly you should just
do one of your one shots about it just
be like a one minute thing I loved it
it's done go
away my favorite Parts the end I I
actually contemplated doing a one shot
on it but it's it's so old now I feel
like it's kind of not relevant maybe
when December when they release the
Blu-ray maybe I'll do it I don't know
but I loved it so anyone listening who's
been asking uh I love Guardians of the
Galaxy I get that problem too right now
cuz I did a I did a cuz I do complete
stories where I dramatically read out
the stories of stuff and I read out
original sin and everyone that doesn't
read the comics assumes that Nick Fury
revealed what he said to Thor and I just
missed it so all I get constant
questions of what did Nick Fury said so
the moment that we find out I'm just
goingon to make like a 30- second video
of just me going he said this now stop
asking yeah like like that's that's one
of the things that people well also
because like I had a speculation on what
the deal was with Nick Fury and then
like I dropped the audio out when I said
it
just to just to like mess with people a
little bit but um but people are asking
me like like what did Nick Fury say to
Thor it's like no one knows knows yet we
don't work there I have no idea like
we're all on the same page man yeah even
in Thor number one like they even Marvel
like blanked it out like yeah ah yeah
that's did have you read Thor number one
bar I haven't been to the to the shop
yet no so this week's I haven't even
picked them up yet I know C the cap
thing came out yesterday and one people
someone asked me today on Twitter like
which one did you enjoy better yet I'm
like funny enough I don't read my comics
on wday Wednesdays I usually read them
on Sundays I'll just have my stack and
then I'll go through them but even some
like right now my sister-in-law just got
married uh before that I went to her new
husband's bachelor party then before
that it was a bachor party so like I'm
actually like three weeks behind so I'm
going to have like this much to read
from this weekend like my wife's not
going to see me for like five
hours I run I run into cuz I live up in
the mountains so we don't even get our
books until Thursday sometimes Friday so
I'm always
behind not as behind as I am Benny oh
yeah you just don't buy
them but reason I brought up the Thor
thing is I want because we all know they
haven't revealed it yeah we've all had
our theories what is your theory on the
Nick Fury said to
Thor um honestly I don't really even
have a theory um I'm not even going to
try to BS you guys
um I'm not sure there you
go I mean I I don't know it was it's a
coin flip I mean my guess is probably
just as wild as the next one like my
guess was that Thor is not the son of
Odin but I mean I don't
know I got another man I don't read
enough Thor for me to actually like be
like oh well there's this there's all
this stuff I could probably draw from
that would create a great Theory
probably something
you're
unworthy you're unworthy yeah that's all
he said you're unworthy exactly didn't
explain why just said it and Thor was
like no yeah I know the secret yeah yeah
I don't know it was it was interesting
to me you know with with that whole
thing because there's been like so many
changes with Thor over the years like
taking on different identities and stuff
but I think this is like the first time
Marvel sat down and said not only is
Thor not worthy to wield his hammer but
like somebody else is going to wield it
instead you know and and that's that's
what's really interesting here because
like they're they sound like they're
replacing four which again I don't know
how long that's going to last I don't
think it's going to last that long you
can't have a character that's been of
Marvel com last very long I don't think
I don't think it is either man I don't
think it Avengers 2 I'm
thinking no
no why would they bring back Thor it's
gonna be like a miniseries it's probably
going to be like six parts and then
they're gonna they're going to Nix it
cuz nobody's going to like
it cuz Thor I hope you don't mind if if
I ruin it a little bit but Thor uses
that axe thing to try to like beat off
Frost giants like well last issue wasn't
even real in this one because they they
show th in the future the like the eight
Monon future yeah and he's wielding the
battle axe but like he's he's pretty
pathetic with that thing compared to
molier like like he he was trying to
fight one Frost Giant and he couldn't M
like he couldn't do it he just fell to
the floor of the sea molier which allows
you to fly control the Thunder spin it
around do all kinds of crazy stuff
random battle a what do you think is
going to win that fight has to have some
sort of mythical Powers he wouldn't have
just picked a random battle ax well he
also was like crying for five days in a
row so yeah no
food I I don't know I think like I think
don't spoil it too much he still hasn't
read it so we don't want to go too crazy
this is true this is true fa enough yeah
although I I will talk I want I want to
mention like how because you mentioned
earli uh how everyone's like oh no cuz
every time like they do a change with
like a character like Spider-Man Peter
Parker's dead yep uh Batman's dead
Superman's Dead Nightwing is no longer
Nightwing he's a spy now everyone's like
oh my gosh this is gonna be forever it's
like any longtime comic book fan knows
you cannot get rid of these aess
characters permanently it could be I'll
even give you five years out but at one
point in time that character will return
they'll be back well the greatest
example of that is Barry Allen he stayed
dead for like 20 something years like no
we're bringing him back
now well by the way he was never really
dead he was just in the speed force
another thing is it gives them a
chance it gives them a chance to try
something original for a little bit like
even if it's bad and people think it's
bad it's still different than oh this
guy's just alive and like with the flash
can run really fast let's just make him
run faster now right you only do that
for so long before you want to try
something different with him well that's
every flash story is like so Barry Allen
can run fast but this time he has to run
so fast super duper fast yeah like oh
but no that's the current running plot
right now is that he's running so fast
that he's broken the speed force and
losing time now that's the whole plot in
the flash he'll become time pretty soon
R around the world and
like see this this is why I can't can't
get into DC Comics like some of the
stories some of the stories you guys
have over there are just so far out
there I'm okay how is this out there so
so Barry Allen has come back in time
because he broke the speed force as the
blue Flash and he's now fighting with
red flash because red flash is the one
breaking the time the speed force so
he's fighting with them and they're
hitting each other so hard they've
broken the speed force further giving
their powers to Wally West didn't they
do that when super in the and Superman
turned red and blue like I've heard this
story before yeah I thought it was like
the man of energy or something like that
yeah I don't
remember that was like the worst thing
they ever did in DC let's completely
change the man of Steels power set yeah
yeah you're like most popular character
let's let's let's mess that up yeah
fighing high from The Death of Superman
let's make him blue the end and next
what we're going to do is uh Batman is
also going to become the god of sun and
we're just going to go with that we're
just gonna see what
happens but yeah I mean I mean like
Marvel's got their their oh God got
their done things too there were scenes
from original sin of just like people
holding the Watcher's Eyes by bys and
you're like how how caught up because
you're three weeks behind Eris how
caught up in original sin are you did
you finish it um no I actually what's
there's two there's two series that I
just have stacks so Futures End I'm
actually I've read like the first two
issues so I'm like 19 issues behind on
Futures End right funny don't bother
it's not worth it don't bother funny
enough I know what what's going on
especially with the reveals and because
I've been reading super Doom that one
I'm up to I'm up to date with how then
the Superman Doom you know they revealed
they like the last splash page so it's
like wait so all those universes pre-52
all everything exists and then I guess
there was a thing in Booster Gold I
didn't read that but I saw the page uh
the page from it because I was like all
over the Internet that day uh so then
you have that which throws back to
couple ISS from the beginning of 52 and
then you know they're like what does he
not know what what did he not miss and
it's just like all this confusion which
I'm kind of I'm kind of over the crisis
things in a sense
I know this is going to I'm like not I
was talking to my friend Tom about I'm
like not another crisis because it just
gets so convoluted and then it's just
you have to read like 50 issues because
everything crosses over into everything
and I'm like I'm not g to buy all the
one offs and all that because then it's
I'm dropping like 200 bucks you know
yeah lot to keep up with you know every
September has been like that for me like
a $400 drop to get all the varying
issues and stuff like that and this year
with feutures in I'm like I don't like
90% of these we're not doing it just
give me my normal pull list I'm good
really bad my my combo retailer did like
a full order of all the Hologram covers
right like just fully stocked like as
many as if he got as many Grayson as he
got Batman's as he got new like Futures
and Earth twos and I'm like dude it
isn't 1995 like you can't do and he's
like yep well
then feel so bad because it's like then
why I cuz I know my shop they give me
the the covers and then the regular 2D
covers and they let you choose if you
want both or which one you want because
I guess you're on the PLL list they give
you first first dibs but it's like $4 I
think per issue yeah like $3.99 yeah
like and then and you look at the stack
and I have like 30 comics in there it's
like okay so 30 times four blah blah
it's like no I'm not doing
this also acur too so like that's I've
been doing all the dc2 action figures
like I have every single one I I've got
every single one up to months ago and I
finally no I started it with okay the
Justice League the just doing the I'm
going to get that and then like yeah
yeah now we're now we're doing now we're
doing Justice League of America okay
we'll do that and and now we're doing
the riv evil villains okay we'll do that
and then at the end of that like I
started picking up Earth 2 and I started
looking in the future and I'm like oh
now we have Teen Titans now we have
justice league dark I think I'm
done I gave up I was like I'm done I
cannot I can't keep up with these this
is just ridiculous now on top of the gr
Capo designer figures yes which I have
all of also they're all like I don't
even have room to display them now like
they're all going in boxes like I come
home and I'm like time to rotate out
well the Justice League has to stay up
but who cares about power ring you're
gone it's so true my wife's like you
spent so much money on toys and they
just sit there cuz you don't play with
them because you're a grown
man like which one would you rather me
do display them or play with them right
yeah so I I I always use the I could be
addicted to drugs or I could be addicted
to toys which my argument too this is a
better spending expense it's fine one
day this may be worth a fortune or we'll
have a garage sale like that it doesn't
work that way anymore you can't be like
I also I also use the excuses where I'm
like it's my job so I could write it off
at the end of the year it's a review
piece it's good it's fine I I do that
too it's a review piece I'm good I'm
good we get the statues under that under
that
pretense so I have to ask you guys
something because my I I just got well
I'm going to get my first complete
series in Death of Wolverine in single
issues that is my first single issue
collection nice let us all hold on
before we go on let us all just uh do a
round of applause for Dave for buying
single issues and not buying the Omnibus
just because I'm sure you don't watch US
Weekly because we're just that little
little nobody's on YouTube's Corner
yeah what you don't know about Dave is
about yourself lift yourself up no it's
fine it's fine I I I like my little
corner In my little corner I can do what
I want no one bothers me
so uh but Dave buys the omnibuses
normally which makes it hard to talk
current comics when we're waiting six
months for Dave to get the
OM let me tell you what happened in 1972
man it was awesome pulls it
out let's
see so by my research on Batman
Nightfall so before before we move over
to to Death of Wolverine because we were
going to discuss that today though I do
want to get eris's opinion on because
you brought up the crisis they're
talking about another one in March yes
now do you think that this crisis is
just going to be a crisis and we're just
going to get new 52 on on track or do
you think that all the rumors are true
and we're abandoning New 52 and going
pre New 52 again okay this is actually a
topic I want to talk about so I'm glad
that you asked me okay
okay all right so like you said the
rumors are basically like they Abandoned
Ship we're going to go back to pre 52
back to the original continuity which
would mean if they're going to do that
if you really look at it meaning all the
costume changes Superman's getting his
underwear back you know everything is
going to be reconed so as a business
standpoint DC probably most definitely
at least spent a couple at least a
billion maybe a couple billion dollars
it's been like three three years in
they've made New 52 action figures
statues this mon series is following it
now yeah the just the promotions alone
at all the cons like everything like and
the Boom in their business that new 52
did in 200
that was exactly so from purely from
that like judging from that I don't
think it would be smart of them or just
as coming from a business point of view
I would say there's no way they're doing
that because you would you would have
established so much new readership and
fan base only to three years later be
like f you we're going back to the guys
we originally had because then at that
point because there's another theory I
heard where they're like okay but they
brought everyone on the new 52 so if
they go back to the original one they'll
understand it more because they're
current with the the new 52 so it'll
kind of you know it'll kind of make
sense that's what I heard I'm not saying
this is my this is my this is what I've
heard that will confuse the crap out of
everybody right I have heard that it's
gonna be that they might do both and
they might move New 52 into an ultimate
line that like they would keep the new
52 going but drop probably like 85% of
the titles and just run new 52 Batman
New 52 Superman New 52 Wonder Woman yeah
and heard another tangent I've heard
that they're going to do new2 as like an
Ultimate Universe and I I could see that
being a like a valid thing and we just
keep the ones that are popular because I
mean Eris you go shopping at a comic
store you if you go to the New 52 rack
like half of those don't even sell
except for like some Niche crowd that
wants to read whatever yeah there's so
many bizarre books on that rack right
now that don't the amount of consolation
cancellations the new 2 has had is
insane I mean they still doing new
titles and stuff what we got they're
revamping just revamping death show
again Suicide Squad again Teen Titans is
got got revamped again just like United
got booted a long time ago animal man go
on and on and on right but so so it's
just like all the a-listers like and the
only reason why Action Comics still
around I be blunt here is because it's
Action Comics wasn't it's Action Comics
everyone knows it yeah it's like you
can't get rid of Action Comics it's like
it's action freaking
Comics like Detective Comics out of all
of my Batman reads I don't like
detective the most I like every other
one detective is the one that gives me
the biggest I've tried out IUS was good
I I like that the Icarus storyline from
Detective Comics just like what that was
the that was the last five issue series
that just happened you got so many
issues that led up to Icarus before it
got any good and I'm I'm expecting it to
drop back off again it's it's the same
thing they're never going to get rid of
detective even if even if they did
anything to it it just it would be just
be Detective Comics whatever yeah that's
true yeah those are it's kind of like
it's bringing me back to Marvel Now like
when they cancel The Amazing Spider-Man
everyone was like oh my God Aris yeah
what are your opinions on Amazing
Spider-Man the canc I'm like they didn't
cancel anything they may told you they
canceled it they've just brought it off
the shelf for a year only to bring it
back what's funny is I even did it in an
episode where I was like mark my words
guys they're gonna be p Parker back and
The Amazing Spider-Man back right before
uh Spider-Man 2 no joke that Wednesday
before the Friday The Amazing Spider-Man
2 came out lo and behold Amazing
Spider-Man one with Peter Parker back as
Spider-Man and who was the villain of
that Arc I
oh elro oh elro that was yeah lizard was
the first one yeah yeah but you know
what I find funny about that because I
was really enjoying superior Spider-Man
and I felt like the last couple of
issues just kind of got sandwiched to
fit the timeline for the movie that
could have easily stressed out a like
Goblin Nation just got totally squashed
to make it fit into the timeline they
needed so like Norman Osman took over
the whole city in two and a half issues
yeah like he spray pained spray painted
a bridge and he's like I took over it's
mine I'm like really that's that's takes
huh like I don't know the Avengers
ignored the fact that it said Goblin
Nation on the bridge yeah but but
bringing it back to what what you're
saying I think they're going to cancel
the new2 or reverted Recon it whatever
you want to call it I my answer would be
no I don't think it'd be smart of them
and even if they were to divy it up
where it's like the Ultimate Universe I
still think you would there would just
be an uproar and then you have people
divided and then it's like I don't know
and then imagine how crowd of the racks
would be at comic shops too and a lot of
comic shops are already small enough as
it is if they div it what I see them
doing with the division would be bring
back a few of the original titles and
that's it yeah a few core ones maybe the
original Justice League the original
Batman original Superman just enough to
appease the people who are like oh I'm
never reading DC while it's new 52
waiting for it to go back just those and
leave the new 52 for mostly what it is
if they um I'd like to see the metrics
on how much new readership came in as a
result of the new 52 and how much
actually stayed like sure they got a big
boost in 2011 but I'm wondering like how
much of that dropped off and how many
like new readers which is to say like
how many non-comic book readers came in
and started reading the book because
like any I I would I would argue like a
majority of New 52 readers today who are
buying new 52 books probably read pre
New 52 books as well like so I I feel
like if you did the change over I don't
think that the loss would be as
significant as all that but I think you
piss off a lot of people like I think a
lot of people be really pissed because
they'd be told basically yeah we brought
you in you're we're giving you a new
continuity you were on the the ground
floor and it's irrelevant I mean I the
reason I'm stuck with even even on the
low points with the new B2 is because I
like the fact that I am the new
continuity I I can follow I don't have
to go grab oh we're referencing
something in 1978 let me go get that old
book now and go look at what happened in
1978 yeah I agree with you like 100% I
think it's just so much I I I am a firm
believer with every generation 20 years
whatever you want to call it you kind of
do have to revamp because it's a whole
new fan base like it's like you know
you're reading when you're comics when
you're 8 years old 20 years later you're
now 28 years old now you want to get
that new generation so it's like you
kind of kind of have to because how are
you going to be expected to go back you
know to like 1950 and get get that
omnius out be like oh what I don't know
what the heck they're talking about when
did that happen you know when did one
when was Wonder Woman able to fly and
now she doesn't have an invisible jet
anymore like when did that happen you
know what I mean so I did she get pants
in the knet
pants well like here here's a problem
that you run into though when you're
talking about like bringing back
characters when you're talking about
revamping characters all right so so
you're familiar with the fact that axis
is coming out if it hasn't come out
already with what axis the new story the
storyline that come that takes place
after original sin it's Marvel's new
upcoming event so for the longest time
Marvel's had some character who's been
like shrouded by mystery and in the
shadows and nobody knows who it is and
people were like who's the world is this
guy that Marvel's bringing back and it
turns out to be Dr Voodoo all right Dr
voodo was a stupid character he was this
crappy like sorcerer brother Voodoo
brother Voodoo yeah he was he was like
this crappy version of like Doctor
Strange like when Doctor Strange lost
his powers from the um the poers he just
quit well no I thought he lost his like
I thought the vishanti took his powers
away because he refused to fight on
their behalf was actually weaker than
that he just quit oh okay he was like
I'm not worthy to be the social Supreme
anymore I'm out well I'm out you have
brother vo who showed up and took over
and the problem is like they're bringing
him back in axis but unless you went
back and like read those old issues who
you don't know who that is you're just
like who's this doctor that's doing that
like that's the new sourcer supreme
what's going on here they don't
understand what's happening and that's
that's the weird thing that you run into
is because a lot of people like the idea
of seeing new characters a lot of people
like seeing old characters make a return
but you have to do it in a way to where
it makes sense to people and it has to
be done in a way to where you can have
anybody walk into a comic book store
look at a comic and one it immediately
grabs their attention like well this
sounds interesting and two like it'll
keep them coming back after they've read
it and I'll be honest uh Len Wayne or
whatever his name is the guy that made
brother Voodoo made Wolverine all that
kind of stuff he's made some great
characters in the past brother voy was
not one of them and he was not the
slightest bit
interesting like I was I was I was
looking for like some awesome reveal you
know I was looking for some really cool
reveal you know in the whole thing we
already know Adam warlock's back so that
doesn't really matter but I was thinking
maybe some cool villain later on is
going to make it return and I'm like so
we've got like this old guy this guy
that no one cares about coming back to
the comics it's like when the orbs sh up
original yeah it's like no one
cares stop TR to make the
Oren to go in line with that what I
think Marvel may be doing with all of
these random guys that no one cares
about showing back up is that seems to
be like their new trend like the Hipster
kind of thing to do with Comics because
they doing it like Agents of Shield that
which you didn't watch it but the the
guy that they just revealed AIS is
absorbing man oh yeah he pops up
occasionally but whaty do you know and
they they're going to bring in Mocking
Bird and not you know they just did the
or and it's almost like they're like how
let's just bring back every old guy that
no one knew about see if any of them
catch on and if they do movie right well
you yeah you actually I was just while
you were saying that I was like well uh
I heard a while back that you know
because with Marvel Studios they
essentially sold a lot of their ALS
characters right so like they don't have
the rights of Spider-Man Fantastic 4 I
think Daredevil just got revered back
you guys might know right Netflix and
all that yeah they're making the Marvel
sure they own again and they own Ghost
Rider again also I got those but like
with Guardians of the Galaxy what a lot
of people don't realize unless you know
you know a lot about or have been
reading comic book for years like we
have the Guardians of the Galaxy is like
a d-list team like they are not an aist
nobody yeah so it's like Marvel they're
a n in a
niche yeah they're like scraping bottom
of the barrel now because they're like
okay Avengers Iron Man Captain America
okay those are like the only alers we
got so what do we got next uh Guardians
of the Galaxy can we make them cool yes
it's like our version of Star Wars
Guardians of the Galaxy yeah it for them
it was like low risk because it was like
either we have a hit and we've created a
franchise out of nothing or it fails and
who gives a [__] it's Guardians of the
Galaxy exactly
they're they're doing the same thing
with the TV shows um I I'm pretty sure
I'm the only guy that watches it but
Ultimate Spider-Man the TV show has been
doing a major Push by always putting
Nova on the team Nova's everywhere Nova
Nova Nova Nova and Nova is conveniently
a 16-year-old kid just with Spider-Man
dealing with all of the same issues oh
and look now Nova's got his own comic
book and now he's with the Guardians of
the Galaxy and you know and like I
remember reading somewhere that they're
trying to use Nova to replace Spider-Man
and they're trying to use the Inhumans
to replace X-Men because I mean that's
what's pretty much going on in the TV
show they just found the terog and
Crystal right well so that's another
rumored movie The in humans which is yet
again like a non-n I mean we know about
it but the average Joe isn't going to
know about Inhumans no I mean I wrote
this big uh this big article on um on
movie pilot where I was just like like
if you guys have been watching if you
guys saw episode two of Agents of Shield
then you're probably wondering with that
obelisque so I just did this explanation
the cre the and humans and the teren
Crystal and teren Miss I was like that's
what all this stuff is and so like
looking at the way things are laying out
it looks like Coulson will probably
become Captain Marvel that the thing is
the teren crystal will probably lead to
either like it encases the teren Miss or
it has a teren crystal and it'll lead to
the Inhumans showing up and so like it's
it's that's that's kind of the thing
that you have with Marvel and I think
that's that's why to this day I'm sure
if anybody regrets the fact of the
rights of the Fantastic 4 and Spider-Man
and X-Men were sold off it's Marvel
because when you when you say like
Guardians of the Galaxy like people look
at Guardians of the Galaxy and they say
wow Peter Quill you know and that's a
really really cool thing but for us
we're thinking like Steve Gerber's
corvac Saga from like you know the
Guardians of the Galaxy in the 31st
century and traveling into the past to
fight the or to help the Avengers fight
off quarterback like that to us is when
you think of Guardians of the Galaxy but
then you Al think of this current
version and so people see the movie and
that's all they see when they see
Guardians of the Galaxy you know they
see Ron and the accusers like some
screwed up role as opposed to what he's
supposed to be in the comics and then
you know like we look at that and we say
well that's not really Guardians of the
Galaxy but the the biggest thing that
I'm afraid of here is that one that of
course with Marvel bringing back Richard
Ryder that they're going to pigeon hole
him that they're going to say well Sam
Alexander is Nova now like he is the
Nova and who cares if Richard Ryder
coming back and they're just going to
send him off to the ultimate un Universe
which is like where they send anybody
they don't want to do anything that's
that's what happens man guarantee they
just did that to the all new X-Men they
they did that that's what they're going
to do here here's what happen figured
We've ran out of ideas go to the
ultimate universe exactly like if uh
it's a punishment you've been exiled
it's sending them to The Phantom Zone
yeah like when the female Thor Comics
come out like once they actually like
start start really producing and if the
comics are total flops if people are
like we don't care about this female
version of Thor then they're going to
simp say okay fine we're going to do
some Beta Ray Bill Stormbreaker magic
and then they're going to send her off
to the Ultimate Universe and Thor's
going to get his own he's going to get
his hammer back that's exactly what's
goingon to happen it always does and
that's what's disappoint does well she
oh if she does well she does well she's
gonna get her own series are gonna make
her like because Thor's gonna be Thor
again
Thor be like Thor or like Thor sort I
would prefer she she Thor Thor if we
have to pick one of those hopefully she
get her name I don't know Smurf F Thor
at I mean I'm I'm excited to see what
would happen I mean Thor's cool but I
mean it is about time for a change I
mean you can only have the same
characters in comics for like so long
before people say okay let's start
moving towards some new stuff and I
Marvel do what why don't they just
reboot Marvel well Marvel now I mean
they've that not the same thing it's not
it's not new 52 I agree no I mean new 52
Marvel why don't they just do that no
well they've already kind
of saying that's aest Rob
serious thanks to Infinity Age of Ultron
traveling back and forth Through Time
snapping everything other people from
other dimensions like all new X-Men just
popping up randomly they're really
discussing the the the rumor mill is
because of everything that Wolverine has
done and the messing with the timeline
we're leading to a Marvel crisis yeah
another
crisis don't worry ER she didn't get the
DC one but Marvel's just going to give
it to I mean if Marvel does a crisis
then what do you do like like we already
know like way The Marvelous the the
Marvel Cinematic Universe is moving in
the direction where you've got like
Chris himsworth who's ready to go he's
ready to be done you know um you've got
Robert Johny Junior who's ready to be
done yeah and then Chris EV Chris
himsworth said he was ready to be done
and Chris Evans said he's ready to be
done yeah I thought Chris himsworth said
that he was ready to stop playing Thor
and move on that sucks there there was
an article that came out that that said
Bert Downey Jr was was hinting at at
staying in the role of Iron Man but he
hasn't come out and said I want to keep
playing the role of Iron Man Iron Man
would be the easiest Robert D JR could
stay Iron Man for the next 20 years
easily if all they did was just super
impose his face on the armor and and
look now he's just Iron Man 247 problem
solved I did hear Chris Evans is ready
to give up after I guess the third
Avengers which then the rumors come in
which it's like wait so we're going to
pull a winter soldier here and then
Bucky's going to become Captain America
or wait now Falcon's in the universe is
Falcon going to be Captain America
because the comics popular they'll do it
exactly yeah I wouldn't be surprised if
Falcon undertook that role because the
problem you have with Bucky Barnes is
they introduced him as a villain in the
winter so in uh Captain America the
Winter Soldier and then all you know is
what you learned of Bucky Barnes in
Captain America one and what they filled
in between Captain America one and the
Winter Soldier like no one out there
identifies with Bucky nobody's rooting
for Bucky Barnes that are watching these
movies they're just like hey he was a
cool villain and he was a really good
fighter and he did that really cool
thing with the knife and that was
interesting you know but yeah but that
that's it they got to have some some
movie to put it into context that he
could be Captain America yeah which
could be this uh third Captain America
they could go in that direction like if
that's what they want they this whole
that whole movie could be leading up to
like you like him you want him to be
Captain America you know third act boom
Captain America well I mean we we had
like a 2C scene where he held the shield
and the internet freaked out he's the
new Captain
America that I was I was at I was at the
midnight showing watching that and uh
yeah like he what I guess maybe he
throws a shield at him or something he
catches it and holds it up for a second
and people were like
[Laughter]
yeah Bucky fans what do you guys think
of maybe the third Avengers movie
actually being a third and fourth
Avengers movie I thought it was a second
and third Avengers movie but either way
splitting one them into two movies like
Deathly Hallows yeah
yep so no you
go so what I was
thinking maybe in the the third movie uh
he could actually die at the end and
then the fourth movie Bucky could take
over yeah something like that but like
you guys were saying like the second
Avengers movie or the third Captain
America movie would not be an
appropriate time for him to just take
over for the whole movie M yeah well the
fact that they're thinking about
splitting the third Avengers movie into
two film says says a lot of stuff says a
lot of under the radar stuff one what if
happens that movie is gonna be big it's
gonna be absolutely massive that's why
I'm saying Infinity Gauntlet and two oh
come on all this says is that they want
money that's all that says no but the
story I agree with both of you I mean
the story the story is gonna be big
enough that you're going to be talking
about like a huge like a huge event
that's going to take a couple movies to
do because we know that they can a ton
of stuff in to a two and a half hour
film they've done it before yeah I mean
it's it's not uncommon but the fact is
that we're going to be seeing two movies
so I'm I'm saying Infinity Gauntlet
hopefully some Adam Warlock involvement
we'll see what happens but regardless of
what happens most likely I think that
what you're going to see is is is like
Eris was saying like like this idea of
some of these Legacy characters may come
back but I think that what you're also
going to see is like the Marvel
Cinematic Cinematic Universe is moving
in the direction of like killing these
characters off if Chris himsworth
doesn't want to come back as Thor
they're not going to do Thor if Robert
Downey Jr doesn't want to do Iron Man if
Chris Evans doesn't want to do Captain
America then I think you're going to
start seeing these characters just go
away entirely in the Marvel Comics
because otherwise you're going to have
people who are going out and buying
comics for characters that aren't
referenced in the movie and they're not
going to know they're going to be
confused and so Marvel wants to like you
know push both things in a profit
driving direction and so if you have
actors that are playing these major
characters leaving then why not move the
comics in a direction where these
characters just aren't going to be there
anymore so Thor's gone Captain America's
gone Iron Man's gone so on but I don't
know I mean it's it's it's weird no one
knows what's going on except in Marvel
so yeah I have no idea they don't
secretly work for Marvel do you Aris
just back behind the scenes
maybe as he wears the Batman Beyond hat
exactly it's no it's to throw you guys
off throw you off he's undercover he's
under dou right um no I definitely agree
like all their movies and comic books
always cuz every time you noce like what
uh the Nolan Trilogy for Batman we got
the Tumblr what does the Batmobile look
like in the Batman comics now like the
Tumbl the Tumblr yeah what does Peter
Quill look like in a Guardians of the
Galaxy in the comics now with the trench
code and everything just like the movie
looks much better well they changed the
whole thing like the uh what was it one
of the one of the issues of Guardians of
the Galaxy that was solicited they like
changed his outfit to be this more like
very blue like streamlined space suit
yeah and then the movie like started to
Trend well in the uh like with all their
teaser images and so they immediately
just scrapped it and then said put them
in a red trench coat and just change the
whole thing like you you can watch the
transition where they were like oh it's
trending well throw it away just like I
can imagine like if people like if they
that goofy helmet before helmet this
weird like biker helmet like and I don't
mean like biker I mean like a biker like
ching ching like red like e shaped visor
or something on this yeah big chunky
blue hel that had all these holes and
things in it it was weird yeah um that's
like the The Flash TV show if that
Trends well all that stuff is going to
get shoehorned right into the comic I
hope that doesn't happen because I'm not
a fan of his originally I think I even
said I was like I was like yeah okay I
kind of like it but then the more as
time went on I'm like I want to redact
my words because no I remember who the
actress is who plays Iris but she is so
horrible I okay I agree with you in that
I I don't like the casting choices
they've made for a lot stuff in that
show but like I I'm going into this
flash because I'm an enormous flash fan
long before this was even announced so I
want to like it so I'm like okay I'm
going to ignore every flash fact that I
actually know we're just gonna relearn
everything as CW wants to tell
me that's the only way I can enjoy this
it's the only way did you not did you
not enjoy the pilot which is funny
because we're not even supposed to have
seen the pilot so oh I love it it was it
was leaked and then it was left there
and like everyone knew especially Warner
Brothers I I liked it for what it was if
you try to compare it the fact that
Barry Allen's really young the fact that
he doesn't look anything like Barry
Allen the fact that the West family is
now a police department and by the way
they're all going to help him out and uh
the origin story now has less more to do
with the lightning bolt oh and reverse
flash is here at when he got made not
we're going to just shoehorn all that
into there and we're going to go ahead
and hint at a crisis and I'm like oh boy
is this could be this could be so good
but it probably won't be I just realized
you're wearing a flash shirt
yeah I I enjoyed the pil episode but
it's funny because like I do I watch
these things with like I guess a grain
of salt or whatever you guess you say
because like I don't expect these epod
these like CW TV shows or Gotham or
anything like I don't expect it to be a
Game of Thrones a house of cards a
Breaking Bad like if you think it's
gonna be on that level you're crazy
deluding yourself they not gonna make
that kind of
show like in the defensive fans like
when Fox comes out and says like we're
making a drama you expect to see I mean
fox has great shows under their belt you
got like house for example an awesome TV
show a really really good drama if fox
says we're producing like we're making a
show like I expect Fox budget money to
go into the production of that show
Gotham although episode two was a lot
better than episode one yeah was let
down in terms of what I what I thought
it was going to be like how I thought it
was going to cross I thought it was
going to be a highquality really good
dark drama and instead like it's like
something that I would expect to see on
the CW it was kind of like we what we GA
you liked it right you liked it Aris the
go one yes but like I said I I go in
with that point of view because like uh
like what Robert was saying you know he
expected like it to be like really dark
and gritty but it's like all these show
like Smallville Arrow Flash now Gotham
then Constantine uh what they're talking
about a Supergirl show I think now
they're all the same type of thing where
it's like you have to know it's a little
cheesy or you're not going to enjoy it
so it's like you have to go into it
knowing yes it's not going to be like I
said like this high quality budget where
you know HBO where they're throwing like
a million dollars an episode it's like I
don't know I I so I enjoy it for for
what they are like they're fun and stuff
but I I don't expect it to be I would
like it to be like of that quality like
you know a blockbuster film or like a
Breaking Bad but it's they're not and
it's like once you realize that I think
it's easier to enjoy it and you're just
like oh yeah there's a there's a
reference to the Joker oh there's a
reference to you know or whatever so
it's like I just enjoy it for what it is
and it's like it's fun I guess yeah I do
that with arrow and I'm doing that with
flash just kind of okay accept it for
what it is don't try to compare it to
everything we know just take it for take
it for a grain of salt but the problem I
had with Gotham is I felt like they
tried to please too many fans at once
and we got a show that just fell in the
Middle Ground there was the the the
comic book references were stuff that
made me go oh I get that but I don't
care about a little girl poison ivy I
don't care about how pink one got the
limp you know like I don't care about
that stuff and then the cop stuff I felt
like they grazed over making it less of
a cop drama but I mean that's that's
just my opinion no I totally agree with
you because all those gripes are the
gripes I had I said in my one shot
episode review of it like I think they
tried to cram they try to do too much
fan service in a sense in one episode
where you know the comedian are like oh
that could be the Joker or there's you
know little Poison Ivy and there here's
you know Catwoman and there's the
Riddler he's at you know Gotham PD now
so like they just did a lot I think it
was just like look guys we're going to
hit the Riddler look guys we're going to
show Catwoman look guys we're going to
show this that way stay like we're going
to get to these people just stay and
watch every week like like the show is
called Gotham like we know they're going
to be there like you can do one or two
villains you don't have to show the
whole gamut like we get it well well
they showed Catwoman Selena like she did
she literally didn't say a word that
whole first episode but she did do a lot
of this she was like yeah like I'm
Catwoman check me out look I'm I'm
feeding milk to cats but see like like
here was the thing this is why like I
really liked eris's video on uh on
Gotham because like I agree with that
with that idea that they could simply
just space it out like just have a
little girl poison ivy appear like the
issue that I had with like episode two
for example is they were like really
building on her character like you had
those two people which I don't know if
they if those are like reflections of
people that exist in DC Comics but you
had those two people that were going
around and like kidnapping people you
know and like the second episode is
great cuz it focused and that's that was
what I said I felt like the second
episode had a focus we're focused
and we're just follow Selena Kyle we're
not going to do thousand one cameos you
know I felt the second episode was
really strong yeah I agree with that too
that's what I liked about it is is after
seeing the first episode and say okay
like it's not what I expected but I
guess this is how the show is going to
be then like going into the second
episode it's like okay you know I mean
there were some parts that were kind of
silly where Jada pink Smith like stands
up and yells for everybody to get out of
the restaurant I was kind of like okay
it felt like a like a spin-off of um of
a god what was that that movie um
Sherlock Holmes a game of shadows where
like he Taps his glass and everybody
gets up and leaves like it was it's it
felt like you know like a writer was
kind of Let's Do A variation of that but
you know after seeing how the show is
going to be like seeing how it is that
it's going to be produced I wouldn't go
as far as to say that like I'm a huge
fan of it now but a lot of that thing is
due to the fact that I just don't read
DC Comics that much but I would say that
it's it'd be something that I would tune
in you know periodically or catch up on
at the end of the week you know yeah I
think how they did the how like uh you
guys were saying how the second episode
was a lot better in the sense where they
kind of try to focus on one thing or you
know you could even do two maybe three
you know depending have little subplots
but I like how the main focus was like
you know who were kidnapping these kids
and then spoiler alert for anyone that
reference the Dollmaker which was really
cool I was like see that's like a
perfect hit where you don't you don't
see the villain you just the name drop
and then you know if you read the comics
you know you're like oh doll maker and
if you don't then in future episodes
you'll find out but stuff like that I
also like that
because like doll maker is a great
villain for that show as opposed to like
trying to have the Ridler in there like
feels
like that'd be so awward killed the
dinosaurs everybody
chill why do we
Aller when that happens everyone jumps
to his lines I mean he had the best
Great Character he's The Great Character
in the comics but every time bring him
up nobody references the great and epic
story lines like Batman annual from like
two years ago that was great explaining
Mr fre we all go not great but what
caused the dinosaurs to
die because Arnold was so good that it
was bad yeah or F Arnold Arnold wasn't
that bad like he had okay he had like
the most cliche one liners ever but that
mean it's Arnold schwarzer name me an AR
schwarzeneger film you've seen where he
hasn't had like a film full of onliners
Junior
okay that that film was that film was
the baby that film was terrible anyway
that film doesn't count there was movie
J no there was it was was the one with
Danny deito no there was no there was no
movie called Junior Danny deito was his
wife and they had a baby and lit like a
little Arnold that movie does not exist
the problem with Arnold Schwarzenegger
is I love Arnold Schwarzenegger like as
much as the next guy he's a great action
star I enjoy his movies they're fun but
the problem is we all can admit he's not
a good actor we like him just because
he's
likable he's he's a good action star
he's got a cool lick a look lick look so
we like him for that not because he's
freaking you know Tom Cruz over here
giving out or like philli Seymour
Hoffman giving out like this awesome
monologue no one knows him for his like
his monologues we just know him for like
his cool action movie so like yeah B
Batman Robin was still a popcorn comic
book movie but at the same time it was
just like a little too Adam Westy in
sense where we didn't you know that was
was the era where we didn't want that
anymore we were in like we want the cool
dark Batman now not the campy Batman and
it didn't work we were we were rescued
from campy Batman by those movies like
Burton made Batman and Batman Returns
which are to so not in that direction
and then they were like and let's go
back to that direction like we just got
out of there to put us back in the hole
like by the way Batman's always going to
be cold that's just he's always Gotham
is a cold place Mr in it let's do
this and the and the bat credit card
just makes sense I mean why wouldn't
Batman make his own credit card oh God
wasn't that from wasn't that like a
commercial like a George it it was it
was in the movie it was a Comm It was a
commercial for the credit card and it
was in the movie like it was cut
directly from the movie they made like
an extended scene just for the
commercial and then it was in the movie
where wasn't he
no poison iy hypnotizes them both Robin
and Batman and they're competing over
who can get her better and like I can go
on adventures and he's like I got money
and at the end of the whole thing he's
like I win that credit card yeah like
each other it's but but see like like
those movies like I know that like even
from a person that doesn't read DC that
much like those movies were bad but oh
yeah like they're fun to watch too like
like they're just like they're fun to
just like zone out to like if you had a
stressful day they're fun to just like
zone out and watch and so they they
weren't like that terrible per se but
for me like you know again I think that
the Christopher Nolan Batman movies in
my opinion were probably the best Batman
movies that have been made to date yeah
like I love like I love those movies but
see like so so here's my question where
does that Christopher Nolan Batman stand
like how does he compare to like Batman
in the DC Comics like at the point in
time when those movies came out
you mean like are
the books like yeah talk how does he
compare like is he the same way or is he
just like a much darker character in the
comics or in the mov in the comics he's
more intelligent yeah oh okay and also
it it makes a difference if you're
talking about Batman in Justice League
or Batman in his own solo Series right
cuz Batman and Justice League they scale
up his powers and his intellect to match
up with Superman he he's already smart
but now he's really smart I'm going to
make the argument here and like I I
don't want to make any listeners orever
mad so I'm gonna I'm G to start with I
love the Nolan Trilogy I really do the
dark The Dark Knight is one of my
favorite movies in general not even just
comic book movies right I like the
trilogy I think Rises was the weakest
but I still enjoyed it right any anyway
in saying that I do think there has not
been an actual Batman movie made now I
say this in the sense like cuz all the
Batman's we've gotten in the movies
aren't really that close to how he is in
the comic books because Nolan was really
all about the realistic so we can't do
this and like even like you was saying
he's not as intelligent and he's just
nothing about him was detective or
really Batman we didn't get any of those
shots where you know fight it like a
gorilla where he's just like all boxy
and like when he knows like over 100
forms of martial arts so it's like why
are you fighting like your robot like I
don't get it yeah well I mean we even
had like a 15minute scene where they
were going over with a doctor about how
much being Batman's taken a toll on him
in only the 5 years he did it or
something crazy which means he can never
be Batman for more than like a couple of
years or else he'll his whole body will
deteriorate I I I will suggest uh and I
said this before the Nolan Trilogy and
I'll say it even after the no Nolan
Trilogy for me the best Batman movie
like the most like appropriate Batman
has never been live action but it's mask
of the fantasm oh yes yes sir yeah
almost a cop out it's almost a copout
because the cartoon was the is for some
the most definitive version of Batman
and number two it's the most like appro
like the most uh
like appropriate right uh you know
version of Batman where it's like he's
he's intelligent but he's also you know
his his Bruce Wayne Batman balance is
perfect and he's also 110% yeah but the
Batman the Animated Series just in
general anything from the inverse like
I'm fan boy that was that was where I
actually that was where I learned all my
stuff about Batman was in Batman the
Animated Series like that's that's where
my knowledge of Batman comes from no me
too because I was like eight years old
when that when that stuff came out so
that's like before because you know when
you're little you I mean I like reading
comic books but when you're little you
still don't like reading that much I
watch you want to watch
like yeah exactly so like i' come home
from school and they would just be B you
know they would do the block where it's
like two in a row or then it's Power
Rangers then Batman like belg and all
that like is coming
out yeah but it's on television right
now so watch Soldier tripping right here
oh my God the the greatest thing ever is
when Batman went over to Justice League
Unlimited I liked the Justice League
show where it carried over the like like
it was the first time you ever saw
continuity they're like Superman to
Batman or Batman to Superman oh now
we're going to Justice League it up and
yep that was great that Justice League
like the the first series and then when
they did unlimited and you were like oh
man they're going to up the Annie and
throw the whole damn DC Toy Box onto the
chable like that was great like every
except for Green Arrow because every
time they Tred in that
book unimited because in that whole
thing Green Arrow is such a weird
superhero that he just he's only good in
select situations yeah and then they
keep trying to shoehorn him into
everything else well he was I thought he
really I thought they I liked every
portrayal in that show I think everyone
nailed it was they did an episode with
uh with like the two gun kid and like
shining night like it it was fun to
watch did they do an episode where
Batman time traveled back into like the
old west and they did that one like
cowboy character that has the scar up
face Jonah for his name right now Jonah
Hex yeah that was in Batman new
adventures though right that was in the
Batman new that was Batman that was that
Justice League Unlimited because the
two-parter throwing it out to your hat
is the second part that go to the Batman
Beyond future R yes awesome well we all
know like at the I think it was the end
of Justice League Unlimited or end of
Justice League where the last episode of
That season was where it throws back to
how Batman Beyond got created which now
if you're reading Batman Beyond universe
or Batman 2.0 baton 2.0 right recently
it just did a three issu story arc where
it goes into more detail and explains
everything about that which that's cool
Al Kyle Higgins is doing great on that
it was he's making my little kid be like
jump with Glee I haven't I haven't
picked up that title because like there
have been a couple of different
incarnation of Batman Beyond and like I
don't know which ones were done like in
the style of the of the show but weren't
following the continuity so like bman
Beyond 2.0 is in the continuity of the
show I'm gonna pick it no it is it's all
he
basically all it is is he picked up
where Batman beond the show left off
that's awesome
so's cartoon series through a comic book
that's so cool uh that Batman Beyond uh
animated feature
return that is another good animated
feature from the dcau yeah my top five
favorites it's so is the Justice League
Beyond is that tied into that whole same
yes yeah it's it's also from because you
know the Justice League Beyond was uh in
Batman Beyond and Justice League
Unlimited yep when that time traveling
episode so it there also it picks up
from the cartoon so he basically is
taking over for Bruce Tim
essentially and now now just real quick
for my timeline sake on DC the Beyond
universe is between the Justice League
3000 Universe which is now so far in the
future we've lost every
superhero technically I
guess they're all in line they're all
conned so when I was younger I used to
watch um Superman the animated series
which was really fun and uh there was
one episode of that I think where
somehow he was time displaced I can't
remember maybe he ended up in the future
but there was some guy named like savage
or something like that oh that's a
Justice League episode was Justice
League episode it was Vandal Savage and
it was that's an amazing episode that's
the death of Superman episode yeah like
like all the all the superheroes are
gone or something like that like I think
all he's like 10,000 years in the future
yeah yeah yeah um there was Al there was
actually my favorite one out of that
super I think it was actually an episode
of Superman the animated series is when
time got screwed up and he I don't know
if he went to like another alternate
reality or something like that that but
it was one where Lois Lane had been
killed and he became like this really
dark like enforcer for uh Lex Luther and
that was a really cool episode like I
really enjoyed that one people knew what
they were doing even they even explored
some of the else World stuff yeah then
like I forgot about that the uh another
thing I just have to throw this out
there because we're in a public forum we
have to talk about it is Michael
Ironside playing Dark Side they will be
never there will never be a better actor
playing Dark Side than Michael oh he
played the I guess he played the voice
of him or he played the voice of of dark
side on Superman the animated series and
Justice League and then they made
Superman Batman apocalypse and they
didn't cast him and it was like why okay
so what of the first major Comics that I
ever got involving Superman I think my
dad had bought it for me when I was when
I was a pre- teenager yeah um it was the
death of Superman it was when doomsday
it was when doomsday had showed up at uh
I don't I don't wherever it is
Metropolis I think it was and had like
just destroyed the Avengers I don't know
I don't remember off my head the name of
Superman I think Superman was in
Metropolis I'm not sure
about here Batman's Metropolis Che hold
on yes yes he was he was in Metropolis
and I check Che my Dooms they trashed
the crappiest Justice League of all time
yeah he he did like see like with one
with one arm actually like he had one
arm literally still like tied behind his
back and destroyed that entire Justice
League and then like over the course of
the comic it's just like beating
Superman to death yep and it was one of
the coolest Comics that I ever read
because it was like oh my God Superman's
Dead I remember at the time the idea of
like bringing characters back of like
redc conning like something I'd never
thought of so I was like what are they
gonna do they didn't
either how are they gonna sell Comics
that's why they were like there was a
Time magazine article about it uh Our
Lady Peace wrote a song about it like it
was a big cultural thing like nobody
really expected that to happen in fact
there's a funny story about the edit the
editors who were working on that story
at the time like for for a couple of
years they used to write like all their
Superman plots up on a big like
whiteboard and some and one of them and
they would always rotate they would
someone would erase or not erase but
write over in like dry erase marker the
end of the story and then write and then
Superman dies and they all had a good
chuckle about it because they're like
well you never kill Superman hahaa but
then like they ran out of
stories and they were like crap what are
we going to do and then they were like
maybe we could kill him maybe we could
do that joke we've been making for like
the last 15 years and and then they just
you know went crazy with it there's
actually that's on I think that story is
on the behind the scenes of the Doomsday
cartoon right animated movie yes I I
remember seeing that that d one was cool
like didn't they like lobotomize him or
something like Superman shot his laser
laser beams through his head and like
yeah through his eyes that Superman
Doomsday cartoon was really weird like I
mean I thought it it was the it was the
first one the first one yeah and like an
H plays Lois and like I don't remember
who played Lex but it was some like
really weird actor and it was like they
played it up where like Lex was like in
love with Superman and it's really weird
yeah it's really a an odd Choice
especially when you have the source
material and they're like nah we'll just
do this crazy thing we'll do it we this
would be fun yeah I mean to me it was it
was it was a cool story to read because
like you know growing up again you know
I I knew that Superman was like this
indestructible man like no he just
couldn't be killed by normal means and
so it was like wow like seeing him and
doomsday like just beat each other to
death was just awesome Dan jur funny
side note about that though the re
because if you saw the cover art he it
was all black blood and I remember
reading that the reason it was all black
blood is because they couldn't show
blood nope but blood is considered red
so if we make it black we can cover him
in it yeah that's how they did it with
Carnage as well with with Carnage's
first appearance all everything was
black blood the world was not ready for
Carnage showing up in mid I would say
that Carnage wasn't ready for the like
that yeah the world still isn't ready
for Carnage his latest appearance was
fighting Deadpool like we don't know
what to do with
car what what can you do like what do
you do with a charact you got a guy you
got a symbiot which is just rabid and
totally insane takes possession of a man
who is also rabid and totally insane and
while they're both rabid and totally
insane together they go on Killing Spree
like how do you make
like yeah how do you tell a story this
what you do is you call it Maximum
Carnage make it okay okay so 14 part
series after the end of Maximum Carnage
what do you do well you make it star
such tent pole characters as death lock
and Iron Fist and firear and Cloak and
Dagger
andbody Sala on Art and you just make it
a big pile of crap yeah you know all all
it was was Carnage killing people and
then riding Carnage Rules in Blood and
then like it was like a 14 issue
Detective comic it was like they were
predating the internet like Internet
troll gets a
get noobs did you end up reading that
one because you look something you're
trying to say here and they're going off
a total
troll I was going to S they saying like
how how would you do Carnage since I
guess he isn't used too often even
though he's like one of if not one of
the most popular characters for like
Marvel so it just makes no sense that
they don't use them more often so
they're like oh let's put him in the
comic book with another one of our most
popular characters Deadpool that's going
to really sell which which did but he
was was based off of the Joker which I
know I think some people would know
Cassidy was you know when they sorry
lost joking here
anyway two yeah right he was take two he
was based off the Joker so maybe if not
fullon copy that you know you can't just
mimic The Joker but maybe if they do
they kind of push him to be more of
Spider-Man's Archen enemy kind of like
closer to the goblin where he's just you
know Spider-Man's always forced to like
stop whatever he's doing because he's
killing people for no reason just
because he hates Spider-Man so maybe try
to mirror that in a sense because
they've openly admitted it that's you
know where they where they got kind of
copied off the Joker same thing with
Deadpool and Deathstroke same that was
like a joke with the two of them like oh
Wade Wilson Slade Wilson let's do this
thing like that well we'll keep it going
so maybe to do something like that yeah
well the problem with Carnage is he's so
it's almost like they like Spider-Man's
too goody to go against Carnage I think
because I don't the the the latest
substantial story with Carnage cuz the
Deadpool versus Carnage thing was not
substantial at all it was just Deadpool
chasing Carnage that's pretty much all
it was yeah um was minimum Carnage where
Carnage got shrunk and went into the
microverse and fought against the
microverse people the micro kns and a
lot other crazy stuff God and even that
it was like they had Venom against him
and Scarlet Spider and both of those
were kind of like oh we we'll kill if we
need to you know and even that just
didn't make much sense I I don't that's
that's why I say like like for the most
part in Marvel Comics you have
characters that do like some crazy stuff
they do some outright stuff you know and
sometimes you got characters that are
generally insane such as the example of
my favorite character mad Jim Jasper
just totally crazy totally insan wait
wait hold hold on hold before we go
anywhere I need to know for the record
Eris he is our he is our like obscure
character guy do you know who Matt Jim
jasp is you do not I I do not oh man
you're missing out you're missing out no
one knows
know who that is about what about the
Magus yeah the Magus that's the alter
ego of
warlock okay okay all right did you guys
hear that I got a lightning storm over
here so I guess if my computer goes out
then that is why so you're not trying to
escape from us yeah I'm not trying to
escape now later on guys
peace lightning I'm out um oh dude
you're missing out man mad Jim Jasper Mt
Jim Jasper was a guy that could warp
reality and they had to to destroy his
Universe to keep his reality warping
powers from spreading but nonetheless um
is he kind of like arm fall off
boy like what arm way I have no idea who
that
is character obscure character
resolution I have no idea who tried out
for the Legion of Superheroes and his
power is that his arm fall off and he
beats people with his
arm that's pretty awesome of the month
pretty awesome that if we're going to do
like our own crazy obscure Justice
League I'm going a dog reer so we'll do
that that's the guy that um welds uh
dogs to dead people's faces
yes Li because he
can one thing I did like though um when
you were doing your your video on like
the top 10 worst superheroes you talked
about a guy who had the instinctive
ability to drive any vehicle
yes like like some of those characters
like some of those listing were were
nuts but um but yeah like like you have
characters that like some of them are
totally out there and crazy but like
with Carnage you just got like a crazy
sadistic guy like that just kills stuff
because he can and and that's like I
mean like how I mean what do you like
even with like Deadpool like he's got a
dark humor and with a lot of characters
he would kill him as assumed to talk to
him like you don't really know what he's
going to do but you still know there's
like this this code that he follows like
there's some measure of logic to what he
does but with Carnage he just just kills
people does things yeah he just does
stuff put him up against
moonight when did he fight moonight
actually I just I haven't even read the
new book but I just picked it up a trade
so good moonight is supposed to be
inspired kind of by Batman true put
moonight up against Carnage
yeah I mean he's he's a super he's a
super rich guy that dresses up in a did
you really say he's the white
Batman I mean I mean that's about as
racist as you can get as people
commenting on my Lantern video wait so
you mean to tell me that the white rings
have all the power and the black rings
are all dead people racist
DC wow but no like I would say that like
like Bruce Wayne's not as cool of a name
as Mark Spectre but still like like he's
I mean he's for the most part Batman in
Marvel Comics I don't really think
there's much doubt about that in terms
no moonight is very different from
Batman no he's no he's okay F okay maybe
the differences give me the differences
between and Batman first of all moonight
has multiple personality disorder okay
so aside from being crazy like else the
other thing is Mark
spect Moon Knight's Alter Ego was
military trained he and that's it is it
yeah yeah
yeah he was with the CIA for a while or
something yeah he was CIA trained he was
special forces like he's he's he's seen
combat another thing is apparently Moon
Knight's weapons came from like some
Egyptian tomb or something like that
yeah the idea they were like they were
made by by some mutant right that travel
back in time like with the X-Men anyway
that never happens that's that's easy to
pinpoint down a mute in
time he had more of like a weird like
spiritual origin yes so like it's dumb
all right
well people in the chat are debating um
molecule Man versus the
beyonder the chat gets a bit weird the
chat gets a bit weird yeah they get into
their own debates it's funny it's funny
to read we we've hit all of the topics
that we wanted to discuss today except
for one final one and Dave was opening
with it and I cut him off and got it
back on the original track so I don't
know if you've been reading it but have
you been reading Death of Wolverine and
since you're kind of a few weeks behind
you may not have there there yeah I
haven't read it it's in my poll list but
I haven't picked it up yet okay so we
really can't discuss death The Wolverine
then well I'm
sorry I was leading into that for was a
question to ask you guys if there's a
lot of times when comic book stores gets
D like damaged
shipments because I know two out of four
of the comic book stores here got damag
shipments of Death of Wolverine and they
couldn't sell me any but because they
didn't have enough for the people who
had
pist that damage comic books happen all
the time my my stores get them and then
I just go back get them when they're
good yeah
am am I the only one who's OCD with like
like comic books like when you pick them
out like B corner back go the back I I
will not grab the one in the front I
will it has to be at least three back if
it's the last issue I go find it
elsewhere I can't have a bent corner I
can't have a crease the corner here
can't be like overly sealed like
someone's been opening and closing it
too much right I'm not that OCD my god
when I read it I go through one time
typically and then I bag and board it
it's it's a true but feel like like a
crazy person CU I'm always like no not
that one back corner that one and then
but I also do that with action figures
too so I'm like I'm looking at like the
paint applications like that one's got a
smudge not that one okay no this
one and you get him because that might
be rare one day and you get the one
that's good because you need him for
display right very well but see like
like being OCD like that makes sense
because somebody at some point in time
bought New Mutants issue number 98 and
was OCD and kept it in M condition and
sold her for like $100,000 so you know
it just depends but pool issue do what
deadpol yeah that was Deadpool's first
appearance that's whoever sold it for
$100,000 is a genius dude it's a it's a
super
expensive like comic to have in very
rare condition like got that did it go
up because I he sold it he sold it in
9.9 condition oh
wow I got my 9.8 on that one all right
let's let's talk about the speaking of
Like Comics are going for a lot Action
Comics one they just went for $3.2
million on eBay
but that's because the unprecedented
grading on that book what was it again
it was like it was in the I think it was
like 8 point something it was like it
was a great great it was like
unprecedented how do you even sell
something that expensive eBay man he so
eBay 3.5 million people have sold their
lives 9.0 condition 9.0 how did he do
that did he go back in time and pick it
up there
like well no there's a video uh a
YouTube video how he acquired it
apparently he bought it from this guy
for a lot cheaper and just kept it in
like a bank bolt for
use and then he's like hey I want to be
a mil millionaire let's sell it on him
yes well that happened wow my wife about
it I was like imagine selling like a
comic book that was like what 10 cents
at the time right and then knowing once
you sell that instant millionaire well
you know the reason you know the reason
why Action Comics number one is is is so
rare right not not just because of its
age broke them and tore them all up back
then with the
com of the paper donations for World War
II right
yeah apparently there's only a handful
of copies in any condition around in
that's the other thing like they're
estimating like 50 I think in existence
from
the wow yeah like me expensive wow
that's the big thing that I'm wondering
about this though is because this
happens this see this kind of thing
happens every few years we have a big
comic I think they just sold like
Detective Comics number one for like
300,000 or something crazy like five six
years ago seems like every few years
some big comic goes for a massive amount
and I don't know about you guys but I
notic because I mean I know s and Aris
you go to the store Dave just started
going to the store but either way you
see kind of like a Resurgence of
everybody trying to grab number ones and
everything again like everyone thinking
that I'll get the next million dollar
book I I definitely see them buying more
number I see I mean everyone like
everybody that I ever see in the store
is always like oh number one but no
one's ever like grabing like you suckers
um I'm gonna go put this in the bank
vault this EP I no it's what yeah yeah
it's pretty much over I know Batman
number one since that title so popular
now from The New 52 uh that issue is
going for like 80 to 100 bucks sell mine
I've I've got every variant for that
that's got to be worth
something just to read it I was like oh
cool new 52 Batman I'll pick it up see
what's going on I love Greg capilo done
and then I was like cool so if you want
like 80s 80 bucks whatever go on
eBay I love 80 bucks and it's like it's
never going to be like what in like 20
years it'll be worth like five like
watch though you sell it and you were
wrong it's like 2,000 I'm a
toolbox I imagine I imagine Magneto
comic will be worth a lot in a while
because it's it's the first time he's
ever had like a solo comic like
Magneto's never had but but what happens
with the com colle
Market the problem with the comic
collecting Market is it doesn't matter
what happens in the comics for the most
part yeah I mean you'll have first
appearances of certain first appearances
of Deadpool Sinestro that kind of thing
those are worth some money but if it's
not a number one you need to have
something extremely significant happen
in it and the problem with the Marvel
Now run is they are mass-producing
everything yeah there are there is no
shortage of any book for Marvel Marvel
Now Yep
they were kind of smart about that with
the new P2 they did the first run and
they were like that's it we're doing the
first run then we're gonna go to second
we're not gonna M we what we have to do
is we have to pay more money for
everybody's Comics to put them through a
wood chipper and then they will become
rare enough to sell for more money right
you want to buy everybody else's Comics
to make us worth
more that's an interesting
scheme that is
that sounds like a really bad super
villain scheme I'm going to become a
millionaire by killing all of your stuff
yeah oh well hell it's like that episode
of Batman the Animated Series when the
Joker's grand scheme was to copyright
fish yeah the Joker
fish I love that episode that is that is
also based off a really killer Neil
Adams Batman book I was wondering if
that was actually based in like somebody
in the comments of that video it said
like the comic was was like it it was
almost toeo Toe with the comic it was
and uh and I was like wow I don't
realize it was a comic oh yeah like well
a lot of the episodes from uh the the DC
Universe are so good because they take
it straight from the continuity oh yeah
and I think the one that everyone still
wants especially from a direct to uh to
DVD or Blu-ray is a Killing Joke oh yeah
like want that very very I think Mark
Hill even said he'll return come if they
do The Killing Joke which imagine him
and Kevin Conroy Killing
Joke prom they couldn't do that in the
Animated Series because it gets too
violent direct DVD it gets like really
rapy and violent and yeah had to direct
the DVD but the Marvel did the same
thing Earth's Mightiest Heroes is great
because it copies comic book story lines
y that that crappy new one Avengers
assembled is not great because they just
beat each other up y I was so bad when
they canceled that Series yeah I don't
know why I mean that was that was like
Justice League Unlimited for Marvel like
it was it was awesome and the theme song
always got stuck in my head always I
would sing it for the rest I remember I
remember being at New York ComiCon when
they when they were releasing the show
like when they were releasing previews
and they just blasted that theme
throughout this and I'm like this is the
worst song I've ever heard it has to
stop because I've heard it for the last
four
hours and then it came on and like now
it's over and I'm like I miss that
stupid song that I hate so much
like in Spectacular Spider-Man
Spectacular Spider-Man Spectacular
Spider-Man I was always stuck in my head
I'm like oh my gosh I can't get it out
if you ever watch there's a show on Food
Network called cutthroat kitchen okay
this is really obscure the last like
lick of that song of the theme song for
cut thr kitchen is also the like the
like the harmony theme for spectacular
Spider-Man and I hear it every single
Monday
night I'm like I'm Spiderman like That's
How It Ends I'm like God damn
it by the way we talk on this we talk
about comic books and the Food Network
that's also on our podcast I'm not sure
Rob kill you in and
we're time for to talk about what
happened on
Chopped oh I miss I miss chopped I was I
was going to go Iron Chef this
week so um so here's my question so are
you going to Comic Con Eris in new uh
Comic Con I no I'm not going this year
next year I will be attending both
though I'll beend San Diego and New York
so were you gonna put them on like the
ultimate spot by the way we're live are
you going no no no no I was I was saying
like it'd be awesome to like meet up and
chill and you know oh yeah for sure so
next year when if you go next year I
know I'm going next year meet up we're
going to both next year this year the
New York the New York thing kind of came
out of the blue for us so we haven't
really done very much we're trying to
plan it as we're going but uh just
because here's out of here's out of the
blue all right here's out of blue airs
Benny gets on and says hey guys you want
to go to New York Comic-Con and we're
like uh sure okay I I have a few
connections to get press fast to Comic
mon later oh yeah two you got have your
passes in two
days like I didn't know you guys really
wanted to go yeah it was okay okay wa
when we first started in may just a
quick little rundown because I know
we're kind of running a little later on
time here and stuff like that but when
we first started these channels up in
May or whatever we were just really
small no one really watched the channels
and I had enough connections to get us
into New York Comic-Con so I brought it
up no one mentioned it to me again until
August when we brought s on the show and
s's like oh you said something about
Comic-Con so I got him tickets
and then Dave and Rob hop on and they're
like what no tickets for us you guys
didn't say
anything I was like hey
whoa we're doing this but yeah it was uh
it's it's getting kind of crazy but yeah
so um do what I was gonna say I will be
going to uh Comic Con here in Dallas
because I'm based out of Texas so I
think the 17th through the 20th I'm
going to that so that yes that should be
cool October yes it's it's like a week
and a half after New York ComicCon cuz
New York ComicCon is what the 12th right
yeah to 12 to the 12 9 to 12th okay so
we should oh since you guys have like
been collecting single issue Comics what
what should I pick up for my three
series
Batman
Batman Journal is really good when you
just read it in one big
sitting
I'm GNA get the trade for that one sorry
Ben no just get on 26 issues I think
we're on what are we on today I think
it's 26 yeah yeah just just spend
$120 if you're buying single issues man
go back and get secret Wars one and two
what be my advice yeah
man secret secret Wars secret Wars one
and two store do you go to Secret Wars
one we've got uh we've got like five or
six comic shops here that all all of
them have like a lot of old comics
but um do what I said if he wants to do
single issues like an older run which
isn't too expensive Craven's last hunt
that is and you can get those pretty
cheap single issues that's pretty that's
good good series an old like collected
volume of it I'm looking at the value of
Secret Wars if he's goingon to buy dude
man gem Shooters gemm shooter Secret
Wars issue uh uh first part like the
secret Wars one is so amazing that's
that's when Spider-Man gets the Venom
$60 you know what man you know you got
to pay to play man you got to pay to
play you can get 26 issues of Batman
Eternal oh man Secret Wars is really
really good all we're doing a uh we're
actually shoot tonight we're shooting an
episode of back issues and we're doing
Secret Wars nice I'm vetoing you can't
shoot that I can't wait to see that so
um all right a so when we uh when we get
back to the point where we're starting
to to close out the podcast everybody
just kind of runs over what it is that
they're going to have going on so give
us the Spiel give us the rundown of what
it is you have coming up by the way body
who's who's watching this and unaware of
who he is and I'm pretty shocked if
anybody was but he's from variant Comics
back variant comics and this is what his
show is going to be doing next week you
do every Wednesday right and then every
Wednesday yeah every Wednesday and I
have one shots that are at random so of
like something I want to talk about or
tomorrow they released a trailer for
Batman v Superman I'll shoot an episode
real quick put up my thoughts on it nice
okay yeah uh but what I have coming up
uh next week is actually going to be one
that people have been wanting for a
while now history of Wonder Woman so I'm
finally going to
everyone's like you did history of toxin
before history of Wonder Woman I'm like
I just wanted to I want to wait for the
right time I originally wanted to wait
for you know around Batman v Superman
but that's like way far out especially
since they put they push it back so I'm
like I'm just going to do it because
I've already done Aquaman in most of the
Justice League and people have been
wanting it so I want to please
them I mean there's I plan things out
the same way myself where it's like oh
look like this this week this month well
not not to segue in but this month I'm
doing the exact same thing arrow and
Flash are coming out so I'm like look
we're doing Flash and arrow all month
look at that how convenient that is yeah
I mean I think there's a lot of interest
out there for Wonder Woman now since
like they're finally getting around to
you know making Wonder Woman Like a big
deal in terms of like cinematic
production so yeah which is about time
okay I know you put it up and I didn't
see it and I I because I I've got a lot
of things going on I didn't see I I know
I know it came out of your channel but
just in a quick one sentence response
how do you feel about the Wonder Woman
costume I like it the brown leather okay
okay I here here's the thing I mean I I
know a lot of the a lot of the gripe I
guess with it is uh it's kind of it's
not as bright it's darker or some people
are saying like like she's got like you
know stripper heels on how can you fight
in stripper heels right uh I I mean I
think I need another picture too because
it's kind of far I guess to tell the
colors it's kind of gritty but you can
kind of tell from people photoshopping
or just bringing up the contrast that it
is going to be a darker blue a darker
red so once we get we see like a trailer
or a better picture I'll have my final
opinion but as of now judging for that
one photo I like it it kind of looks
like the costume from uh Wonder Woman
Earth 2 if you guys seen what you it
kind of looks similar to that Wonder
Woman costume yeah but overall I I like
it okay no real no real gripes no real
anger because yeah because I've seen the
exact same argument everyone's like what
have they done to her she's so slim and
slender and not bulky and no colors and
but that's I don't understand like been
thin forever that's what I'm saying like
have they not seen especially new 52 Jim
Lee drawing her or Terry dos or like
anyone like she
she hasn't had muscle M she's barely had
tone now for the last like five years
like probably they're all just basing
their opinion off of like the Darwin
Cook Justice League new frontier Series
where she was like right like an
Amazonian like I don't think anyone
wants a female bodybuilder Wonder Woman
so
China nothing against Zena but we don't
want Zen no dude Zena nothing man we're
talking about China from 1997
WWF if they didn't if they didn't win a
for movie in like '94 I would have taken
Zena though Lu would have been an
awesome one yeah oh L Lucy Lawless back
when she was doing Xena Warrior Princess
no question man yeah she had a going on
they're crazy boy Rob's going on his
creepy whatever man
whatever Sorbo as Thor back then if they
Kev would been great now I don't I don't
know man I don't know how I'd feel about
a Kevin Sorbo Thor movie it' be it'd be
like a it'd be like a David Hasselhoff
Nick Fury movie it'd be like exactly
very 90s yeah it wouldn't be too great
but anyway so um so s so you said you're
filming back issues tonight yes we're
shooting an episode of back issues
tonight that go that'll go up next
Thursday or a week from today uh we'll
be doing Secret Wars by Jim shooter and
the Gang from Marvel
1984 uh this week we had an episode of
back issues came out it was Superman
Birthright a lot of people were
complaining that we didn't do enough DC
a lot of people are complaining we don't
talk about books we like last week's
episode was es was especially hairy
because we did zero year and uh we
weren't huge fans of zero year and Scott
snd was like sorry you didn't like it
and the chat up and they were like they
were like you don't like anything DC
Zack Snider's killing it I'm like L dude
I love it but like zero year I wasn't a
big fan of and they were like do
something you like and I'm like
earthright here you go Mark Wade [__]
Nails it yeah that that was quite funny
we had we had s did you elaborate a
little more had a slight pretty much
somebody showed s tore apart zer you
tore it apart that's what you did T it
apart look there are a lot of elements I
liked but like somebody linked it to
Scott Snider who then went and watched
it and commented on the video
Yeah he was by the way the classiest
dude ever drops F bombs like you
wouldn't no I'm just kidding he he was
so freaking cool about it and like he
but like he he said like he was just
like sorry you didn't dig it man I like
like you know I'm glad you liked other
things I've done I'm like no man like I
like part of for year it was just you're
backtracking now you're like no no no no
no you
misund red saw my video like you gave
Ridler Riddler dignity but you created
an uncle for Bruce Wayne that's dumb and
that's cool like like but uh and then we
CH we chatted on like in private because
I wasn't like I I didn't want to open it
up I want to be like hey everybody let's
watch our conversation so I like
contacted him personally I'm like the
dude I'm like my Dopey show is not worth
like you feeling bad and but he's really
cool like just was he was really cool
about it and you know what's going to
happen man he's going he's going to be
in New York and he's going to come
walking up he's going to be oh I'm going
face and he's like you're gonna be like
yeah I'm s he's gonna be
like no it's me I'm the my face be like
hey backy just like yeah it's me he's
like woom yeah I like how they how they
explained where the penny came from
though with his uncle like that know
like there were a lot of different
things that I really liked I just
thought it was a little over complicated
I thought it was like really bloated I
just thought there were too many details
like it was just there's a lot going in
there and it was like one after the
other and you know anyway this week we
did we did Birthright I like that a lot
that's what we did and uh yeah and we're
reviewing Lobo number one uh Thor number
one and Death of Wolverine number four
or three whatever the newest one is on
off the rack cool awesome uh Benny did
you tell us what you had going on yes
you did okay
um messing around I'm messing around I
see how it is I see I'm not important
anymore that's how that
works no um I'm doing Deadpool the good
the bad the ugly this week that's still
coming out I already did uh Batman Court
of the owls no doing Deadpool good bad
the ugly uh next week is going to be
Flash the one through five run uh Batman
Knight of the owls and Deadpool original
sin had to do good bad the ugly first
because you can't tell you can't explain
the story of Deadpool's daughter without
explaining how he got a daughter yeah
doesn't make much
sense U but yeah that that's what I'm
doing and then all month I'm doing Flash
and arrow stuff because it's October and
CW is going to give us a bunch of
Smallville shows
yeah makes sense man um Dave do you have
anything coming out this week yep I'm
gonna do uh the underside civil war
finally finish that up then hopefully
I'm going to be able to in in one video
do a a review of the collection of
criminal oh cool nice that's a Indie
comic series right it's yeah it's two
deluxe hard cover volumes that I have so
I'm going to do those yeah you've been
telling me to to read that but I just
haven't had time to I need to check it
out at some point you know what's a good
Indie series that I don't know if you
guys are reading Five ghosts from image
oh yeah dude I'm loving that I've been
reading uh low is what I've been reading
mostly it looks good I haven't read it
yet but it looks good I haven't read
that either it's like a Fantastic Four
family at the end of the world and they
have to like go save everybody but they
have no powers I'm trying to wait on a a
deluxe uh collection for uh
what's it called Saga saga's so good
yeah because that's coming out soon and
I I just got the first volume and I was
thinking like I was really tempted like
I want to get two and three but then I
was like nope I'm gonna
wait Omnibus gotta Omnibus it hey I'm a
big fan of the the deluxe hard covers in
the omnii OM collection I've never
bought an absolute Edition but I think I
would buy an absolute edition of uh
Saga I love how been here for like an
hour and a half and he already knows
what to mock Dave
for you and your omnibuses man
Omnibus gotta get on them single issues
man oh man um all right for so for those
of you guys who have been screaming at
me for like the last three days on
Twitter and in comments and in private
messages asking me if I've given up or
died or something like that no I'm very
much alive and yes part four of Infinity
Gauntlet will be out tomorrow so people
people have been like ring cuz I I
stopped at like the worst point in time
I'm like in the next video we're going
to see what happens when all the
superheroes get together and try to
fight Thanos and that'll be in like
three days so so people were getting
really mad at me about it you've done it
better than I did because I ended cour
of the owls as the night of the owls
begins I'm like and all of the Assassins
they jump into Gotham they're ready to
fight and we'll be back next week yeah I
mean I mean I mean there's what what can
you do but but uh Infinity Gauntlet part
4 is when stuff gets it's good because
part one through three is all dialogue
part four is where all the action comes
in so we get like super dialogue so it's
just so clunky and it it's you know it's
it's what you'd expect when you sit down
I mean it hasn't changed like if you've
read uh the new Thanos Revelation I
think it is the one that just came out
that brings Adam Warlock back um it's
the same thing it's so terrible the the
comic even gets to like this weird place
it gets to this weird Sal so on board
with
this Jim St J Starin makes really good
St lines Jim St is awesome when it comes
to making Cosmic story lines Jim Starin
is not good yes he does he's not good
with like one-on-one conversation I'm
saying like it's just like why is it
have to be so boring okay maybe maybe
Jim star's DC stuff sucks but no it does
he wrote Death he wrot he wrote Death
family like but Marvel stuff Jim st's
Marvel stuff is awesome Jim Starling
killed Jason Todd okay nothing that he
has ever done for Marvel aside from like
making Adam Warlock an egg lives up to
that making him an
egg write most of Infinity Gauntlet or
am I wrong he wrote it all he wrote it
all almost almost all the stories in
Marvel that involve Thanos um um the
Silver Surfer yeah Adam
Warlock pip the
troll characters he l oh oh yeah oh okay
ASA would say this Rich history of yes
Rich
[Laughter]
well he like kind of like co-created
like their Cosmic
Universe matches up for what he did for
Marvel like like killing off
Robin That's I consider the death of
Jason Todd to be a a it's like the death
of Gwen Stacy from for Batman it's like
a cultural Touchstone for Comics I I'll
agree I'll agree with that it's a great
story I I just like red hood in general
too how they how they bought him back
and everything the Red Hood I expected
it to suck but I read under the Red Hood
and it was really tight and what I what
I liked was uh I don't remember who
wrote it crap who who wrote under under
hood um well anyway he wrote the DC
movie adaptation as well and so it's
which was a great movie yeah that's a
really good one yeah that's the only one
that I don't mind Kevin Conroy not
playing Batman you know I'll agree with
you I'll agree with you on that one
everybody else I'm like no but like that
guy I think the guy from from Star Trek
like the the guy who plays the the
captain uh no that Peter Weller I know
does Dark Knight Returns is that it's no
no no um no there's a guy I don't
remember okay but uh he's never played B
I think he played Batman in the Teen
Titans Cartoon not the Teen Titans Go
but the young justice cartoon okay like
that guy came back to play Batman in
under the Red Hood and that cartoon
series right the guy who's also a really
good at voice of Batman I think is
the guy who voices Batman in Arkham
Origins he kind of sounds like Kevin
Conroy he does he does a nice he yeah he
nailed it better than the guy in like
year one I don't remember who played him
in year one but that was wasn't it like
a guy from like a Gossip Girl type guy
you know like CW shows or something he
was so
horrible speaking of go what are your
opinions on I
Zombie by the way uh nobody's told you
yet about s he is are
like like our nitpicker that doesn't
like anything that isn't
original yeah okay like like did you did
he's like Superman Earth One is terrible
and I thought it was it was good yeah I
didn't I thought it was a good
contribution and a change as opposed to
the goody goody Superman of old
no and that's how we're gonna end this
just salting no so I think at this point
we've all given our exit our exits our
outros more than like 20 minutes ago and
I think just ranting rambling so thank
you guys so much for joining us for the
weekly poll this week as usual I'm Benny
for Comics story and that's Rob for
Marvel explain that is s for TV little
house that is Dave for Comics reviews
and that is Aeris I will never get his
last name right for variant
Comics konz konz did I get it Kon see I
got it wrong
[Laughter]
and as usual if you guys enjoyed the
show please give it a like give us a
subscription to every one of the
channels because we really do appreciate
that follow us on Twitter because we're
all talking and having Wars because I
hate Rob on Twitter because he doesn't
do it right uh I guess I don't know and
as usual we will see you guys next week
with the four of us normal maybe one day
we'll bring back AIS I don't know Dave
seems to have really hated him so we'll
check it out next
week anyway you so much guys and we'll
head out today see you guys later
peace see you bye